und bringst deine beiden Trops noch mit
wir wurden ins bnbcker Revier allarmiert
für mich ist wenn ich zu solchem Einsatz
gerufen
werde BA erstmal so ein bisschen
Anspannung auf ja man überlegt so ein
bisschen wie könnte man die Person
vorfinden wie sieht die aus erst
bisschen zurück trenn gleich und
verschieben dann liegt da wir haben
hinten vorne geerdet ver
zurück
ja verstanden wir bereiten Zugang vor da
geht man natürlich schon ein Stück weit
auch über seine
Grenzen weil
dem so eine Person wenn die von der Bahn
überroll wurde natürlich schon schwer
schwer verletzt ist und auch schwere
Verletzungen am Körper
[Musik]
hat